Willie Harold how well-known is his
story and what unique angle does he give
you into the film not only for who he
was but the way you're gonna follow him
and not his victims it's not a
well-known story even in the MC lund in
the north of Germany it's not that
well-known you know a generation before
mine still kind of remembers but it's
not a case that has been talked about or
written about a lot I I was looking for
a story that would enable me to you know
sort of look at the dynamic structure of
National Socialism because we have
certain national myths that say the V
Moffitt was clean they were not involved
in atrocities they were not
ideologically driven they didn't partake
in massacres of course that that's all
not true as we found out in the late 80s
but there are other national myths that
are still kind of alive and we ran
straight into them when we were looking
for government funding because a lot of
people were trying to block our path and
and kind of burry the film and not
having have it funded because they felt
the film was amoral and that it you know
besmirched or soil to Vermont amoral
because the approach was clearly one
where we were telling the story from the
point of view of a perpetrator and that
was kind of a there's only two films in
the entire film history of Germany since
1945 that are told from the perspective
of the perpetrator which is death is my
business which is I think 1984 it's it's
a fictional biography of food or hosts
ironically of course written by a
Frenchman if Germans wouldn't write it
and 1977 was the van's a conference
which is of course where the final
solution was negotiated and agreed upon
those perpetrators however our primary
architects of the system and and making
a film about the dynamic structure to me
involve making a film about the back row
of perpetrators about the people who
were the boots on the ground who kept
the system running for whatever
you know not always ideological and and
so I came across the story and I
realized this story would actually allow
me to do a bit of an allow system
analysis because it doesn't just involve
the very bottom you know of the ordinary
soldier but it goes all the way up to
the top in the court scene where you
actually meet you know the generals and
the actual architects of that of that of
that system but when you're telling a
story from a perpetrators point of view
you have to make sure that you honor the
victims of that perpetrator so how does
that reveal itself in the way that you
and your cinematographer Florian Bauhaus
shot the film what was important
visually from what was committed in
terms of how you wanted to represent
something that actually occurred but
also honor the victims who were targeted
by him
we actually dialed back what they really
did I mean we they threw hand grenades
into that pit and you know body parts
were flying around so we we we kind of
drew a line and at a certain point and
said okay this is not something we want
to we want to show we had to show a
little bit because I have to I think you
have to understand what it means to get
shot with a flak I mean it's not the
best tool for you know murdering people
in a pit and I think if you don't show
any violence at all if you don't show
the brutality of what is being done to
the to the prisoners
you also betray the victims so so my
first instinct was to not show very much
at all and then I realized but you know
it'll it doesn't mean anything you don't
feel what happens to these people and
Florian was insistent that we would also
always for every scene with the
prisoners do these very long pans
because we wanted even though we we
decided not to have a character we
identify with on the other side of the
fence we wanted to perceive them as as
as human beings in a frightful situation
we never shot anything inside the pit
that wasn't an editorial decision that
we made afterwards that was just
something we said we would we
want to do their other exam and I'm not
saying you know you can't do that it's
just for me it wasn't possible to do I
didn't want to exploit the violence
dramatically too much if you look at
Angie Vytas katene for example there's a
massacre I don't know if anybody have
seen anybody has seen that if you
haven't you should it's it's really a
terrific film and and it has a massacre
at the end of it and that massacre is
shown in my new detail now you have to
know the backstory is that Vytas father
was shot in that massacre and his mom
lost her mind
subsequently to that to that murder so
so for vitai it was in a sense and
exorcism and he had to just approach
this an entirely different way you look
at a Rosselini movie he does it entirely
different again he'd never even shows
you know muzzle flashes because to him
that's too dramatic he just shows people
pulling triggers for for in some of his
World War 2 films so where do you hope
people think about despots differently
or how this story ties in to what's
happening not just here but across
Europe right now
I think yeah I mean it's unfortunately
happening everywhere and nothing has
been a greater surprise to me in my life
I thought we went you know past the dark
ages and we went through you know the
Enlightenment and Renaissance and who
would want to go back you know and we've
gone back and there's there a lot of
strong men who are who are using a very
very sharp nationalistic chauvinistic
Sanna phobic rhetoric to to my in
people's fears because it's a much
easier emotion to mine or to create than
anything rational based you exploit
their fear I think what we're witnessing
again and again you know here in this
country and in Poland and in the Czech
Republic and in all many other places is
that you have people who play lip
service to to the form of democracy but
what they're really doing at every turn
is they hollow it out and they
follow it out by ignoring the norms of
democracy and of course you know there
is no form without a norm and and and I
I think what we tend to forget and I
found us
I found this surprising you know after
9/11 when a lot of civil rights were
were you know disappeared that that
nobody seems to understand that
democracy is not a right it's a it's a
privilege and and I and I think you know
we have to be vigilant and it always
starts with rhetoric and that's
partially the little bit of analysis I
mean there's a there they're three steps
toward massacres that are always in
place no matter whether it's Africa or
Bosnia or Indonesia it doesn't matter or
Germany it always starts with rhetoric
it always starts with of them against us
rhetoric with a with a dehumanizing
rhetoric and the rhetoric always paves
the way for action there's no way you
can have this kind of sharp rhetoric in
the world without people taking action
and of course the people with the
rhetoric can say oh I didn't say that
you know but for example you know there
would be a speech during during you know
gnashing - there would be a Hitler
speech on the radio and five hundred
miles to the to the to the West somebody
would be listening to this speech and
nobody said please drag all the Jews out
of the houses and beat them up that was
not part of the speech but part of the
speech was and it was of course all code
as it is now you know we have to defend
the German blood we have to do this we
have to do that and of course the people
listening to it go and this is back to
the dynamic structure of National
Socialism people hearing it go okay we
know exactly what to do you know we're
gonna drag them all out and we're gonna
beat them up and and after you know in
in our cultural environment you have to
append all judeo-christian notions you
know all the things that you've been
taught
to be true or no longer true which I
can't even imagine what kind of whiplash
that must be and then everything that's
normally illegal becomes legal and and
the way to get there of course is
through lies and through threats and
through coercion but also because people
don't step in the way this is not you
know this movie is not a is not a
classical tragedy in the sense that you
know in the third act the kings heads
gonna come off there's nothing faded
about this story never was this this
Massacre happened because of every
choice no matter how small by the people
involved in the story no matter how
peripheral they all played a part and
when nobody says no you know terrible
things happen and I guess you know I I
mean I'm very I started this project
twelve years ago and at that point
people said to me friends who I would be
you know share it with said why would
you do that to yourself why would you do
that to us
and I and I maintained that it was going
to happen again and again because it's
human nature and because the membrane
between chaos and civilization is paper
thin and and sadly in the last four
years the film has become more relevant
on that happy note Robert thank you so
much for coming and thank you for
bringing your film to us